[Música]
hola a todos estoy segura que más de
alguno me ha visto en la televisión
otros me han escuchado por la radio pero
la mayoría me ha visto en las redes
sociales y es en nuestro celular donde
nosotros pues vemos las redes sociales
vemos memes y también los compartimos
razón por la cual quiero que hagamos una
dinámica y agarremos nuestro solar con
la mano izquierda porque estamos ya
terminando esta edición de tedx ex y
quiero que se animen un poco y también
se concentre así que levántese por favor
todos levántense y agarren su celular
con su mano izquierda muy bien ok y
ahora nos vamos a estirar estiramos
nuestra mano
aquí estiramos y tocamos el celular muy
bien cómo hacerlo hacemos nuevamente
estiramos estiramos tocamos el celular y
lo ponemos en silencioso porque quiero
que pongan atención
ok ya pueden sentarse muy bien
el título de mi charla dice uno de cada
tres pero 1 de cada 3 que les cuento uno
de cada tres hondureños ha padecido o
padece de un trastorno depresivo
era usted
será usted
serio
vamos a ver
no funciona
no funciona ahí está chan chan chan soy
yo definitivamente soy yo la que padece
de depresión acá
me diagnosticaron y me diagnosticaron
depresión
en el 2015 depresión recurrente ansiedad
bueno no es fácil hablar de este tema en
público y cuando me dijeron renata vamos
a hablar gente de ex y muchas emociones
pero si queremos que conté es cómo es tu
historia con la depresión y obviamente
no es bonito no es tan bonito admitirlo
no es la primera vez que lo hago tampoco
ante un público pero siempre es un poco
raro hablar sobre esto y sobre todo en
honduras porque siempre hay un tabú con
el tema de la salud mental es decir
pucha tengo una enfermedad mental
siempre me pone un poco nerviosa pero
porque la gente lo ve a uno como si
fuera raro en este país entonces
no es sencillo tocar este tema pero la
diferencia entre la primera vez que
hable sobre la depresión y hoy es que
hoy me siento mejor
[Aplausos]
ahora bien para que todos estemos
entonados y entendamos qué es la salud
mental bueno la oms se lo define como un
estado de bienestar un estado bienestar
el cual la persona va a ser capaz de
hacer cuatro cosas número uno
identificar cuáles son sus cualidades
para que es bueno para qué sirve en la
vida de verdad a veces a nosotros nos
cuesta número dos la persona va a poder
lidiar con el estrés de la vida diario
sin pues sin digamos dejarse caer
entonces la persona sigue adelante
número 4 la persona también puede
trabajarse una persona productiva en su
trabajo rendir frutos y aquí número 4 la
persona puede apoyar a la comunidad
entonces son cuatro cosas que define el
bienestar la salud mental de una persona
si está bien o no
y
la salud mental es súper importante para
el desarrollo de la persona pero también
para el desarrollo y la estabilidad de
las comunidades y es fundamental para la
manera en cómo nosotros vamos a pensar
la manera en cómo vamos a manifestar
estos sentimientos a interactuar a ganar
un sustento es decir trabajar y también
a disfrutar de nuestra vida en la salud
mental entonces buena para el desarrollo
de las personas para que las personas se
desarrollan profesionalmente
personalmente en sus vidas pero también
para la sociedad creo que es importante
que recordemos esto ahora bien que es
una enfermedad mental exactamente lo
contrario de lo que habíamos hablado de
una persona que de repente ya no sabe
cuáles son sus habilidades no sabe para
lo que sirve y tiene bajo autoestima se
siente inútil es una persona que de
repente el estrés lo abruma no sabe
seguir adelante con el estrés es una
persona que no logra levantarse de su
cama no lo haga trabajar
estudiar en mucho menos es una persona
que logra apoyar a la comunidad porque
si nosotros no estamos bien con nosotros
mismos cómo vamos a hacer algo por la
comunidad entonces la enfermedad mental
son molestias o interrupciones que lo
que hacen es que nos afectan en la
manera en cómo pensamos la manera en
cómo percibimos las cosas en las
emociones nuestra conducta nuestra
relación con los demás cuando a mí me
diagnosticaron con depresión yo era eso
miren yo me sentía inútil me sentía
triste no sabía para qué servía me
costaba levantarme de mi cama no había
terminado mi maestría
me sentía vacía usted no tiene quedará
bien complicado y yo no lograba avanzar
en la vida no lograba avanzar de manera
personal no lograba avanzar de manera
profesional y tampoco pues en la medida
formativa no lograba seguir con mis
estudios entonces no es no fue sencillo
el hecho de
no saber qué estaba pasando conmigo
hasta que me diagnosticaron y nosotros
tenemos que aprender a diferenciar
cuando estamos tristes cuando esta
depresión esta tristeza se convierte en
depresión cuando se convierte en una
enfermedad cuando digamos tenemos un día
gris un día en que nos sentimos bajados
pero de repente este día gris se
convierte en un mes gris tenemos que
aprender a diferenciar estas cosas y
sucede entonces que queremos ser
productivos queremos hacer algo por
nuestras vidas pero no lo logramos
porque tenemos algo detrás de nosotros
esa cosa rosadita que se llama depresión
y nos abraza y si no sabes que no van a
hacer nada no van a hacer nada y cuando
esos síntomas de tristeza de soledad de
ansiedad de miedo se apodera de nosotros
es ahí cuando tenemos que darnos cuenta
que algo está pasando obviamente eso no
nos impide funcionar normalmente
entonces es ahí cuando esa tristeza se
convierte
una enfermedad también son síntomas
digamos que nos aislamos de los demás
nos sentimos demasiado en seguros
perdemos oportunidades no los dejamos no
logramos avanzar pero también nuestro
cuerpo no lo dice mucha gente me
pregunta a renata porque anda con el
pelo corto porque siempre te cortas
porque no te vas a crecer bueno yo mejor
de mi pelo porque cuando un día me
estaba bañando en 2015 y yo sentía algo
en mi espalda y ok era un pucho de pelo
que está pasando estoy enferma y fui al
médico me hicieron todos los exámenes
físicos y no tenía nada de mí se sabe
que tenéis que ir al psicólogo y fue
gracias a que mi pelo se empezó a caer
que fui al psiquiatra al psicólogo me
hice todo lo examen y menos sabéis que
vos tenés depresión de nuestro cuerpo
también nos puede decir si está pasando
algo malo con nuestra cabeza ahora uso
el pelo corto porque me gusta y me veo
bella porque ya tengo un montón de pelo
ya logré recuperarlo
ahora es elección pero no siempre no
siempre me gusta contar esa historia
porque voy a mantener como otra vez
recordar esos tiempos ahora es normal
que como seres humanos que somos
presentamos miedo sintamos amor rabia
tristeza e incluso pues alegría somos de
los humanos nos sentimos esto todos los
días pero nuestra salud mental está
sujeta a estas cosas que sentimos y si
de repente todos esos sentimientos nos
abruman ya es un problema nuestra salud
mental también está sujeta a cosas que
nosotros no podemos controlar
precisamente porque somos somos humanos
por ejemplo factores individuales como
las características genéticas biológicas
inteligencia emocional por ejemplo a mí
cuando me diagnosticaron con depresión
vamos fuimos a estudiar que había pasado
con renata cólera en esos traumas que
habían provocado que preció tuviera
depresión nos dimos cuenta que yo lo que
tenía era un desbalance químico que
tiene que cómo voy a controlar eso no
puedo controlarlo entonces factores
individuales que no puedo controlar
tengo depresión factores como el
contexto social
digamos la situación socioeconómica de
nuestra casa donde estudiamos donde
trabajamos las oportunidades de repente
a comer pequeña nosotros mi familia es
mitad brasileña mitad hondureña y
vivíamos en vinimos a vivir a honduras
yo fui la escuela y hablaba me toca
hablar tres idiomas me tocaba hablar
portugués español y francés y yo era una
mezcla terrible porque no sabía español
entonces a mí ni compañeritos me hacía
un bullying eso pudo haberme afectado
también y mi salud mental entonces el
contexto social que me afecta está fuera
de mis manos no podía hacer nada pero
nos afectó también nuestra salud mental
y por último algo que afecta en estas
elemental también son los factores de
nuestro entorno es decir cómo se vive en
el país cuál es nuestro acceso a
infraestructura acceso a servicios
básicos pero también cómo es la
violencia de género y también como la
violencia en general o la violencia de
nuestros derechos
razón por la cual es uno de cada tres
hondureños padece de un trastorno
depresivo y es algo un poco serio de
escuchar pero es cierto vivimos en un
entorno que no nos ayuda mucho en este
salón de 300 personas digamos 100 de
ellas padece hay un trastorno depresivo
siento un 1 conmigo así que yo que le
para los que están por ahí también
calladitos yo que le por ahí que alguien
levantó la mano ahora bien esta charla
no solamente para aquellos que creen que
puede estar padecer algún trastorno
enfermedad mental sino para aquellos
como batman y superman choca le que
ellos no tienen ningún problema pero
ellos también tienen que informarse de
lo que es la salud mental para poder
ayudar al pobre robin que está como solo
por ahí entonces las personas que viven
tranquilamente tienen salud mental
tienen que saber aprender sobre este
tema para ayudar a los demás ahora bien
es normal que todos sintamos irá el
problema es cuando esta ira nos controla
es normal que todos sintamos inseguridad
es exactamente lo mismo cuando no
podemos salir adelante porque nos
sentimos mal por ejemplo yo a veces
siento inseguridad me toca salir en la
tele con chavas lindas altas guapas
delgadas y escuché la reina está la
chaparra y aquí me siento inseguridad
pero eso no me quita el sueño lo mismo
con la desesperanza a veces podemos
estar tristes pero el hecho de que no lo
podamos levantarnos de nuestra cama eso
ya implica un problema ahora qué sucede
nosotros vemos estos memes
y nos sentimos identificados con ellos
le podemos dar like compartirlos y estos
demás pueden a veces reflejar la manera
en que realidad como nos estamos
sintiendo entonces los memes han venido
a revolucionar la manera en cómo nos
expresamos y cómo nos comunicamos lo
cual es algo muy bueno porque porque en
honduras hoy un país donde es un estigma
hablar sobre salud mental nos permite
expresarnos podemos expresarnos con
imágenes decir me siento triste no estoy
bien con memes y nadie nos va a juzgar
porque si venimos nosotros escribimos
con un estado en facebook hoy me siento
triste entre violeta y miren aquello se
hizo la víctima aquí pero si nosotros
subimos un meme podemos igual expresar
lo que estamos sintiendo y no vamos a
hacer tan juzgados entonces están estos
están acá los sentimos identificados con
ellos y con solo vernos sabemos que la
persona pues se está sintiendo triste o
que incluso puede estar admitiendo que
padece depresión o que algo le está
pasando la cosa es que tenemos que
identificar cuando nosotros estamos
compartiendo estos memes o nuestros
amigos están compartiendo estos memes
y son llamados de auxilio porque
exactamente no de risa ok pero digamos
que fulanito viene y comparten mesas y
todo el mes o nueve de cada diez meses
son sobre esto entonces son son llamadas
de auxilio o pueden serlo de verdad la
persona está pasando por un momento
difícil y está pidiendo ayuda con memes
entonces tenemos que estar atentos a qué
es lo que estamos publicando y qué es lo
que está publicando a nuestros amigos
porque por ahí puede ser que estemos
padeciendo de alguna enfermedad o
dudamos o creemos que podemos estar
padece una enfermedad y nos dé pena
admitirlo entonces tenemos señales de
alarma que tenemos que saber identificar
en nosotros o en nuestros amigos por
ejemplo cambian en estado de ánimo un
día estoy feliz otra y hasta súper
triste sin razón cambios de
comportamiento demasiado miedo qué miedo
que no me permite avanzar falta falta de
interés cambio del estilo de vida la
persona está desconectada la persona
duerme mucho la persona duerme poco la
persona come demás come de menos perdía
el control abuso del alcohol drogas
acciones violentas pues estas son
señales que nosotros vamos a ver tratar
de identificar en nosotros o en nuestros
amigos ahora viene la parte importante
que es la empatía si nosotros logramos
identificar estos estas señales en
nosotros nuestros amigos hay que sentir
empatía y esto es un poder que nosotros
los seres humanos deberíamos de
desarrollar
la empatía es decir cómo te estás
sintiendo estoy viendo que están
publicando un montón de memes extraños'
queréis que hablemos escuchar a la
persona no juzgarla es súper sencillo lo
que pasa que a veces se nos olvida lo
que significa la palabra empatía
entonces el hecho de que vamos a
restablecer nuestra salud mental es
sentir empatía es el hecho de escuchar a
nuestros amigos pero sobre todo el
diagnóstico y no es que nosotros vamos a
auto diagnosticar buscando test en
internet y nosotros mismas sino fijate
que fui a la charla de renata y vi que
vos tenés esos síntomas vos tenés
depresión no no va a ser así vamos a
apoyar a nuestro amigo a que busque
ayuda profesional aquí que se
diagnostique que haga tratamiento y que
sobre todo vaya la terapia porque les
cuento eso es lo que me ha funcionado a
mí lo que me funciona a mí el
diagnóstico el tratamiento y la terapia
entonces recapitulando en honduras una
de cada tres personas padece o padeció
de un trastorno depresivo esto tiene que
ver mucho con el entorno también pero
con factores que nosotros no controlamos
la empatía es indispensable para que
recuperemos y que la gente pueda
recuperar
la salud mental es muy importante para
la sociedad y para nosotros mismos para
poder desarrollarnos como personas los
memes han venido a revolucionar la
manera en cómo nosotros nos comunicamos
pero tenemos que estar atentos a esas
llamadas de auxilio tanto nuestras como
de nuestros amigos entonces quiero
dejarlos con este mensaje de final y es
que no podemos decir que nosotros
gozamos de salud si carecemos de salud
mental
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]